son portrait robot a été dessiné ces
derniers jours un monstre aquatique
aurait été aperçu dans le plan d'eau de
l'île de loisirs de 50 ans li bin ces
dernières semaines une nouvelle prise
très au sérieux par les équipes de la
structure tous les ans on entendait
quelqu'un qui vienne me dire j'ai vu
quelque chose dans les temps c'est gros
c'est énorme je suis inquiet pour mes
enfants étaient là et c'est vrai qu'on
n'y prête pas beaucoup d'attention
là ça fait quand même une vingtaine de
témoignages en trois semaines donc donc
bon on est vigilant ces signalements
fonte est quoi une ancienne histoire
connue des membres du club de voile
installé depuis 1992 sur l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines il
ya quelques années un navigateur aurait
touché avec son bateau une créature
verte avec des écailles sur le clando
attaquer on sait pas mais en tout cas il
a heurté quelque chose depuis bas il est
immobilisé parce qu'on a pas réparer la
personne a pris un peu peur aussi et
c'est pas trop enfin c'est un peu flou
tout ça il va falloir qu'on rejoue
d'imposer cette affaire et on ne sait
pas trop comment le problème c'est qu'on
ne l'a pas revu depuis
il est parti s'il a laissé son bateau
est pour l'instant mais comment cette
créature at elle réussi à rejoindre les
eaux de saint quentin en yvelines selon
les responsables le monstre de plusieurs
mètres pourrait venir des étangs de
hollande et aurait pu traverser les
yvelines par un passage souterrain il
paraît qu'il y aura des cavités assez
importante
je sais qu'il y avait des études qui
étaient en cours mais qui sont un petit
peu arrêté avec avec avec la copine mais
ils ont repéré une grande cavité de plus
de 30 mètres de diamètre voilà c'est
encore à vérifier pour l'instant les
responsables ne déconseille pas la
pratique d'activités sur la structure
mais interdisent les baignades les
mesures supplémentaires pourraient être
prises si le monstre aux yeux rouges
refait surface
[Musique]